[Musica]
vado in nepal ogni anno e tutte le volte
che arrivò al controllo passaporti ha
detto guardi documento e voi mi chiede
se sono buddista ma ha vestito così il
secondo voi che cosa volete che gli dica
mi viene spesso da rispondere che sono
un attore e sto andando a kathmandu per
girare un film che in fondo è anche vero
perché tutti facciamo la comparsa nel
film la nostra vita
ma partiamo dall'inizio
una mattina di 40 anni fa mentre mi
facevo la barba davanti allo specchio
con le guance insaponate mi sono chiesto
che cosa volessi fare da grande
avevo un lavoro facendo il bene già mi
piaceva questo lavoro avevo un ottimo
stipendio
ero libero ma che cosa volevo di più
dalla vita
la risposta mi è venuta immediatamente
voglio fare qualcosa che tutti possono
fare ma che nessuno fa e non mi ci volle
molto a comprendere che dovevo cambiare
la mia vita avevo bisogno di una
rinascita
attenzione non ero disperato ero felice
la fortezza era qualcosa di più a cui
doveva spirare e quando dico rinascita
non intendo dire che uno deve aspettare
di essere morto come dicono i buddisti
che poi rinasce ma che deve lasciare
perdere senza indugi quelle vecchie
abitudini che servono soltanto a
sopravvivere ma non servono a crescere
dunque rinascita come partenza come ri
partenza come creazione di nuove
opportunità per una vita migliore
ogni mattina quando noi ci svegliamo è
una rinascita è un'apertura rinnovamento
non sappiamo cosa succede dopo
e anche ogni nuova esperienza e una
rinascita
abbiamo da affrontare situazioni nuove e
quante volte nei momenti difficili come
quello che stiamo attraversando ci siamo
ripromessi di cambiare ma poi per
pigrizia o per attaccamento alla routine
quotidiana
non ci abbiamo nemmeno provato noi
esseri umani siamo dei veri campioni
quando si tratta della pigrizia
io invece in quel momento proprio in
quel preciso momento ho accettato la
sfida
decidendo di agire subito ma con
ponderazione come dice il tema del
nostro incontro festina lente in 24 ore
ho abbandonato la mondanità
ho abbandonato il tennis o habana lato
gli amici con cui andavo alla sera a
divertirmi ma non ho certamente lasciato
il lavoro che avrei poi abbandonato più
tale
ed eccomi qui 40 anni dopo a parlarvi di
corso scoperto nel corso del mio cammino
e a suggerirvi qualcosa che anche voi
potete fare con buoni risultati
quando affrontiamo un'iniziativa nuova
dobbiamo sapere che per farla sviluppare
bisogna coltivarla coltivarla proprio
come avviene per una pianta
avete presente il seme di una quercia e
piccolo così ma se ci sono le giuste
condizioni cresce e genera un albero
enorme pieno di ramificazioni e di
energia
ma le cause principali della nascita e
della crescita di una pianta sono
numerose
il seme il terreno l'acqua il calore lo
spazio ai quali dobbiamo aggiungere il
tempo necessario per la crescita della
trasformazione
lo stesso succede anche per le nostre
iniziative
ci vogliono l'intenzione la pazienza la
perseveranza il sentimento e gli altri
ai quali dedicare le nostre attenzioni
gli altri proprio gli altri
l'obiettivo finale è la connessione con
gli altri che sono le persone con cui ci
confrontiamo ogni giorno ma che sono
anche le cose che ci stanno intorno gli
animali la natura tutto quello che ci
circonda
io ho capito questo è riflettuto molto
su come dovevo relazionarmi con gli
altri e la tesi della non violenza
sostenuta da gandhi che allora era molto
di moda mi ha affascinato non violenza
non vuol dire soltanto che non dobbiamo
usare parole e atti violenti ma che in
nessuna circostanza e in nessun luogo ci
deve sfiorare il più piccolo pensiero di
nuocere a noi e agli altri più piccolo
pensiero questo mi sembra un buon punto
di partenza ma non ero abituato a
pensare così non ero certo un santo e mi
ci voleva un addestramento meglio se non
troppo faticoso naturalmente e quindi mi
sono arrovellato doveva pur esserci un
modo facile per iniziare e alla fine ho
concluso che questo modo poteva essere
l'amorevole gentilezza anche la
variabile gentilezza non fa parte della
nostra cultura
facciamo fatica a metterla in pratica e
soprattutto può risultare difficile
svilupparla nei confronti della gente
io avevo le mie antipatie non ero pronto
ad abbassare la guardia temevo di non
essere compreso e infatti può capitare
che l'altro antipatico o no non sempre
si è disposto al dialogo cioè noi gli
rivolgiamo un attenzione ma lui non la
accetta quindi ho deciso di provare a
esprimere la mia gentilezza verso le
cose era molto più facile quando
accarezziamo il nostro cane o il nostro
gatto
sentiamo che si produce uno scambio
totale di energia e noi stiamo bene
allora ho provato a farlo anche con le
piante con le foglie
foglie di una pianta si possono
accarezzare i paletti petali di fiore
senza decidere il fiore soltanto
sfiorandoli con la mano o tenendoli per
un attimo delicatamente fra le dita sono
uno scambio sono un contatto con le cose
e quindi mettendomi alla prova in questo
modo ho scoperto che è un'esperienza
sorprendente questo gesto che è
diventato ormai per me abitudinario
perché io lo faccio spessissimo io lo
chiamo accarezzare con il cuore perché
nell'esatto momento in cui si attua
genera un effetto che possiamo
paragonare la primavera in natura
d'inverno tutto sembra bloccato cul
ma poi al primo raggio di sole spuntano
germogli e fiori e altrettanto avviene
con la gentilezza perché la gentilezza
far star bene noi e gli altri
e ricordiamoci che anche solo uno
sguardo amorevole può essere immediato
conforto che una potente dell'indizione
ma semplicemente far capire con lo
sguardo che noi ci stiamo e voi fino a
oggi forse avete pensato che per
esprimere amore
il modo migliore sia la parola allora vi
siete sbagliati e una colla
cinematografica la parola è certamente
un efficace medicina ma può anche essere
un'arma pericolosa
e a questo proposito vi vi propongo un
piccolo esercizio quindi mettetevi
facciamo una breve meditazione mettetevi
nella vostra posizione non non
accavallare le gambe
rilassatevi e chiudete gli occhi e
visualizzate davanti a voi un bastoncino
di incenso acceso e osservate il fumo
che sale in verticale formando una linea
dritta
adesso immaginate di soffiare su questo
fumo e fate un soffio di filo
e vedete che il fumo si scompone e si
sparge tutto intorno per tornare a
formare una linea dritta
ci vorrà del tempo
adesso potete riaprire gli occhi come il
fumo che abbiamo appena visualizzato la
nostra mente è un'energia sottilissima e
fragile per sconvolgerla basta una
parola maledetta o mal interpretata e
questo è sicuramente successo a tutti
voi ma è anche successo a me dunque le
parole si prestano all'ambiguità e
possono creare confusione
l'amorevole gentilezza invece non genera
equivoci e viene immediatamente
percepita come un segno di rassicurante
presenza soprattutto a parte chi ha
bisogno specialmente da chi è smarrito
vulnerabile cholo ha bisogno di un
consiglio di un'attenzione ma io col
tempo anche verificato che l'amorevole
gentilezza non basta semplicemente a
manifestarle dicendo ma sono dalla tua
parte si appoggia sulla comprensione
delle condizioni dell'altro
molto spesso chi ci fa del male a
problemi che lo fanno soffrire e non ce
l'ha veramente con noi ma deve trovare
il modo di sfogarsi e noi facciamo da
capro espiatorio
quindi in questo caso quando noi abbiamo
capito che l'altro sta soffrendo
allora non basta perdonare perché è
stato cortese ma dobbiamo cercare di
aiutare
e questo aiuto che noi diamo è
un'importante regalo perché quando
prestiamo attenzione a qualcuno anche
solo per pochissimi minuti gli stiamo
offrendo qualcosa di noi un pezzo della
nostra vita ed è un pezzo prezioso
perché la vita è preziosa e noi qualche
volta presi dalle nostre illusioni
l'aspettiamo anche un po allora molti di
voi mi diranno ma sarà anche preziosa ma
vivere e faticoso e certo è vero ma che
cosa c'è che non sia impegnativo
nell'esistenza pensiamo alla fatica che
fanno le api che volano continuamente
passano da un fiore all'altro alla
ricerca di una piccola goccia di mettere
sono instancabili e noi invece alla
prima delusione ci fermiamo ci
deprimiamo e non cerchiamo altre
direzioni
eppure nella vita ci sono infinite
possibilità di rinnovarci ma noi non
sempre siamo disponibili al cambiamento
ognuno avrà i suoi problemi e io con
questo discorso non intendo certo
proporvi qualcosa che ora per motivi
vari non avete la possibilità all
intenzione di fare ma vi garantisco che
con poco sforzo potete da subito attuare
un cambiamento nella vostra vita
praticando l'amorevole gentilezza e a
questo proposito vi rivelo un piccolo
segreto produrre questa energia
rigeneratrice non è di fini
basta agire con sentimento il sentimento
e per noi quello che il calore è per la
natura aiuta a maturare i gesti d'amore
illuminano la vostra mente è quella del
prossimo e lasciano sempre un segno e
sono certo che se non vi stancherete di
essere gentili con lui anche il vostro
peggior nemico cambierà il suo
atteggiamento aggressivo nei vostri
confronti
e credetemi chi si sforza di essere
gentile alla fine diventa spontaneamente
buono perché a forza di farlo si agisce
spontaneamente anche nell'amore vole
gentilezza e il campo d'azione per
praticare la gentilezza è infinito
infatti i tempi attuali e le ricerche
della scienza le neuroscienze ad esempio
ci portano a riconoscere che il mondo è
una grande realtà globale fatta di
uomini animali piante fiori montagne
cieli tutti interconnessi tutti
strettamente interconnessi e tutti da
porre al centro della nostra attenzione
e tutti i bisognosi delle nostre
amorevoli cure qualsiasi cosa ha bisogno
di un po di energia
quindi se dovessi definirla direi che
l'amorevole gentilezza è sicuramente una
qualità dello spirito improntata
all'ideale del bene e dunque facciamolo
diventare il nostro migliore compagno di
viaggio perché il bene è un energia
cosmica onnipervasiva che nutre ognuno
di noi ha infatti quando amiamo
ci sentiamo uniti senza bisogno di
parole ed emanava una luce che tutto poi
tutti può riconoscere quando quando
siamo innamorati che tutti ci vedono
raggianti
è la chiara luce radiante di una mente
serena che è in sintonia con le
vibrazioni degli altri del mondo in
nepal bambine palesi incontri dicono
namastè la master vuol dire rendo
omaggio alla luce che è in te e io
vorrei precisare meglio la luce che è in
me riconosce la luce kent e se noi
impariamo a rivolgere ogni giorno questo
semplice ma profondo saluto a tutte le
cose che ci circondano
possiamo sicuramente arrivare a quella
pace interiore che coincide con la
fusione della nostra mente nell'armonia
del tubo da mastella a a ricordatevi che
i grandi cambiamenti
iniziano dalle piccole cose e proprio
dire con discernimento e un sentiero
graduale che richiede decisione e
ponderazione festina lente appunto il
titolo del nostro incontro
a questo proposito voglio fare un
augurio semmai domani o dopodomani o in
qualunque altro momento della vostra
vita decideste di essere pronti a
provare a fare gentili possa odiato di
questa amorevoli gentilezza generare
infinito occasione di gioia per voi e
per chi via carlo e possa la vostra
gioia dare fiori e fare frutti e possono
questi frutti andare a beneficio di
tutti gli esseri auguri e fatemi sapere
grazie
[Musica]